Recently, had restaged after nine full months of cutters, clinic protocols still
staged three colon cancer. Two more was seven centimeters, now seven point five
centimeters. New colon, the sigmoid colon, circumferential wall thickening suggests
colitis. Stable to minimally decreased lymph nodes, a seven and all most very small
largest, went from nine millimeters to six millimeters, clean liver, clean lungs.
Medical team recommended radiation with chemo pills, followed by chemo, followed by surgery,
same recommendations as diagnosed with RNA, definitely pushing it on. Not too excited about
radiation or chemo, open to surgery, but with surgery alone, there's a risk from not removing
cancer. If you follow all the recommendations, petty no complications, they give you a 75,
three percent chance of success for five years, continue with protocol and distance,
metastasis and 15 percent comments. So yeah, it's hard when you're given these percent
tiles with oncologists because they are such rubber numbers. There's so many people that
do different things, aren't just doing chemo, radiation, surgery, drop off. It says, I just
don't know how they could actually keep giving you projectile numbers. Now because the truth is
you probably already knows somebody here that has had a similar cancer to theirs that did everything
medical oncology, you know, recommended and their outcome wasn't good. It doesn't be yours won't
be because you're doing a whole lot of other things. So again, I'm not against doing any of these things.
It's, you know, again, the way I decide for myself is that I look at what their statistics are
and then I, you know, pray about it and say, okay, and this is what I want to do. I don't want to do
chemo. Let's say that's me, but I'm open to doing chemo. God pushes me in that direction. So you
really got to feel if you're being pushed or led in that direction. I really, I can't comment beyond
that, whether a person should do a medical treatment. That's kind of thing, but it's a simple struggle.